welcome to this video part 19 of the pre
World Championship match series and this
is the last game presented here for
champion Vishy Anand and for the last
two games one games one game each for
for both players I chose to present the
game from each player's
up to now Korea highlight I guess thank
every every chess player has some sort
of the kind of tournament of his life
the event that he will be mostly
remembered for or simply the event where
everything sort of falls into place and
you can go through chess history and
always find those events of human let's
say start with recent just history for
Fisher certainly has run for the World
Championship with the Intel zonal 1970
in Palma then the matches where he beat
Larson and come on off 6-0 this is
certainly Fisher's finest hour
culminating in the dimension Reykjavik
but he certainly played even better and
the candidates beforehand for Coppola
certainly Daenerys 1994 for Kasparov
probably like 1999 it's difficult for
Kasparov though because he had such an
amazing career that you can take many
tournaments but probably Wieck 1999 is
the most remarkable one he won the
tournament with 10 out of 13 and among
the games he had this fantastic game
against Apollo very hunted down the King
on t1 he that's white the black king
traveled all the way to d1 y at forum
Kramnik it was certainly the match
against Kasparov in London where he beat
Kasparov very convincingly and if we
come to Arnold of course the subject
here
of this serious his best performance to
date and an absolute highlight some his
Mets win against Kramnik in 2008 I think
everyone agrees that in 2008 when he
played Kramnik this was the best honored
ever played and just to put it into
perspective I think if you would come to
that level in the match against cows and
I think honor will win the match
whatever Carson is doing how that would
win but it's hard to hard to get to that
level um all right so let's see we
traveled back to 2008 the watch champion
should mention bond are not already was
world champion winning the title in
Mexico City in this tournament
I already presented the game I think it
was the game against Greece shock
writing and screw shock Wahine won the
tournament and then kramnik had the
right to challenge honored in a match to
7 2008 in Bonn Germany just a couple of
miles away from some myotonia bonus not
far away and they played the 12 game
match and honored one very convincing me
and you could choose some any of the
three wins or good interesting games and
I'm going to show game five here it's a
hard choice it's a hard choice all three
wins my honor and or the draws even were
interesting but I'm going to go for Game
five
and at the time are not already let the
match at one point he had won Game three
in the same opening that we see in this
game so let's get ahead I'm playing
black it's the semi Slav one of his main
defenses throughout his career and
chronic goes for e3 crowning also has
played Bishop g5 often but he somehow
didn't down to to choose it in the
measure not always played
age six here the Moscow variation where
white can give up the Bishop c4 a good
central controller or oops this was a
bit too much nope
I can play Bishop h4 leading to this to
this very sharp
gambit line we actually saw this later
when I played with the white pieces
against her chronic in a later merge
situation Kramnik played that as black
to sharpen up the the fight he needed to
win badly but this wasn't on the agenda
form for chronic he played III just like
he did in Game three he repeated the
same opening night be d7 okay both
players of course repeat Bishop to d3
and now in the capture so we have the
main line of the so-called Moran
variation Bishop d3 and here's the first
interesting parting of the ways here
black has three moves on main moves
available are maybe four moves on ants
may choice always most Bishop d7 in
recent years after the mansion ball he
also more frequently adopted this Bishop
d6 move which is a relatively new
development the discern move this is
plate this is also on the means that he
played to beat aronia in this amazing
game at the beginning of 2013 a game
that softly would be long in this series
he of the great games but I wanted to
present games that I haven't shown
before on video so if you want to see a
true attacking gen bio not go back to
January 2013 and my channel to the like
and Z start us your tournament Aronian
again
Donald um yeah that's another move um
this is an a6 this is the oldest move
and I not had never played this before
the bond match but this was his
preparation a6
of course intends to play a direct c5
while this should be seven does the
other move intends to play before and c5
not playing a6 at all mostly and here we
get this immediate c5 and this leads to
very sharp play now white basically is
now faced not faced the forced forced to
push some of the central pawns either d5
or e5 both as possible Cromley chose
ePHI this is the may be the oldest
continuation it's all dating back to the
1920s
yeah and black here is forced to capture
on deform there's no other move you
don't really have a good square for this
night for instance you don't want to get
it to discard of structure this looks
very ugly white place is six soon and
will gather an amazing attack you have
to play this capture on d4 and at first
this looks looks really great because if
white captures you will get a five and
just win but White has funny countenance
he takes on b5 just removing the knight
on c3 from the attack and yeah now it's
a kind of a complicated position or
kinds of pieces are hanging and black
here has more than one possible move can
take here can play Knight g4 all kinds
possible but a lot here goes for the
simple recapture and he had already
played this in game three and presented
a new idea here at the time a new idea
white of course needs to recapture on f6
to get back the piece and now
takes f6 this was known before the match
but what was new is what's coming next
castles Queen b6 22 attacking the spawn
and here
allons-y a new idea it's almost a new
idea I think there was like one one game
played years ago before before the match
where Bishop d7 this is the new move
other let's say we selected move Bishop
d7 this was the new idea and we should
pause for a moment to to have a look at
this position yeah what is black doing
he said positioning this Bishop on the
best possible diagonal but he doesn't
really care about the b5 pawn so when
the white can what can get get this pawn
and then also would pin the night on d7
the whole position is really geared
towards keeping the King in the center
like reality can can castle hear how to
imagine how he could could accomplish
that the whole position is really a kind
of yeah let's not say irrational but
it's really a very calculation heavy
position and this is in accordance to
Ananse match strategy for this match in
bond he really made a conscious decision
to go for lines that are more concrete
than abstract words about calculation
and sometimes also a bit about yeah an
imaginative play because he thought that
in dry technical position Kramnik is the
better player which is probably probably
true
and this is exactly the opposite
strategy
compared to his strategy against Apollo
in Sofia 2010 we tried to play as some
yeah played really dry technical chess
if if possible because the power of is
in fact the complete opposite of
chronics trying to play very sharp games
based on on preparation and this shows
and this is an enormous strength of
harlots nowadays that he has some gotten
to to know his own strength and has a
good analytical skill for judging how to
how to play against a certain opponent
and this is also what makes me curious
about this match because in just on
paper it's pretty clear that countless
the favorite yet the much better results
but it's not clear at all in one-to-one
match if this really translates into
points if an on somehow manages to to
find the key to two playing cards and I
have no idea what this key might be but
but we will see maybe he has some idea
how to how to how to play exactly
against this opponent okay so let's get
back to the game I talked much but I
hope you enjoyed it anyway
okay so right now took on b5 Kramnik m
in game 3 we had exactly the same
position in game 3 I'm sorry I am I read
my notes wrong he played the same in
game 3 then the next point is here are
no place rook g8 exactly he's the one to
get in the new idea first in the third
match game he had played Bishop to d6
which is also interesting it's not not
bad
and analysis after the game showed that
Bishop e6 is is a perfectly all right
move on it continued rook t1 by the way
and then Luke g8 so it's it's a similar
to what happens in the game where Robert
g8 was played immediately so Cromley is
the is the first to get in the novelty
which is always a clever strategy if you
somehow know that the opponent has
prepared a new move of course if he lost
the first game with the slide he will
deviate somehow and you get in your
surprise first always a good strategy
and it's obvious that the rook belongs
on g8 it's just a question for you put
it on g8 now or one move later and now
this is the new move order route g8 yeah
and um Bishop f4 plate yeah white always
can take on check on d7 if he wishes so
but this does not really need too much
at first it looks a bit strange having
the King on on d7 but where exactly is
the attack it's really a problem black
has this fantastic bishop and you don't
really have any attacking pieces also
note that the pressure on the long
diagonal can get dangerous really
quickly just for instance let's say it
moves like that black can even go for
this idea just attacking here and
something like that even when the
exchange immediately it's tricky you
shouldn't really take on this heaven
this Bishop is setting up a pin and you
shouldn't take too quickly it is an idea
but not not well-timed at the moment he
played Bishop f4 which seems okay and
now Bishop to d6
logical this piece needs to be developed
and why not exchange him you need to get
this also out this piece because here at
one point want to play King is heaven to
connect the rooks so a logical move and
now Bishop d3 this also makes lots of
sense because it blocks the G file so
the rook is not so effective on g8 and a
nun place f5 yeah just strong active
moves it intends to play a for harassing
the bishop on g3 yeah here of course um
Cromley cam had to make a decision it's
it's difficult in this position to to
decide on move because there are many
possibilities and obviously it's very
complicated he played a rook F 2 c1
putting a rook on the C file um
you also could could have considered
other moves for example just to to have
a look rook f31
looks like a good idea at first
attacking the pawn but this is answered
by f4 and this can get tricky really
quickly never look at that bishop here
and now the very strong means rook to a5
yeah what exactly is this move doing
let's let's check quickly it now attacks
the bishop and the bishop needs to do
something it probably has to take check
and now the problem is you cannot take
on deform this is just a disaster
oops I suppose a bit too much I was
still looking at this check this
position yeah what should why do you can
play something like that getting the
King out of out of the lung out of this
G file but black is simply a much much
better here it's got this active pawns
to active bishops and this is just
placed very badly like him also easily
protect his pawn if he wants to even a
move like in five is sometimes possible
okay five is a very remarkable idea in
this position they are also tactical
ideas let's say like 95 setting up this
pin here black can also react by the
funny move f4 oops
d3 first sorry first you need to play d3
attacking the Queen the editions after
that now White has some problems or
pieces hanging at the moment if you look
at this continuation oops
like his black is winning using this
this pin and it's really going downhill
very quickly with two coming it's a it's
a very dangerous position very dangerous
Kramnik plate platform play the finals
we played rook F c1 as mentioned before
and now the next move so our plays are
just good strong to the point you played
f4 and Bishop e7 this
is the kind of move that is yeah it
looks like an easy move to play but you
still need to decide to to actually do
it it exchanges the bishop on h4 which
does not really make such a great
impression and the bishop on d6 looks
like a fine piece so why would you
exchange edge for the good point is
simply you need a square for the King on
is having to connect drugs this is why
there should be seven as good move just
exchanges the bishop and make sure you
have fun have a place form for your king
yeah a four plate it's um it's better to
do it that way takes here note that you
cannot really take here this is hanging
but hey it also check so he took on edge
for this is the right one Knight takes
and now King e7 as mentioned the king
wants to get out of this pin and you
want to connect rooks this has some been
accomplished now yeah of course there
are there are always tactical things to
to be considered in this position what
about Knight a5 for example yeah black
can just retreat him and g2 is the
problem so this check leads nowhere
my basically needs to go back in this
position if you will feed this to a
computer it will sometimes come up with
the remarkable to move g3 which I'm sure
no strong human player would consider
opening up the long diagonal and also
something like just to show this is
something that would instantly frighten
you if you are human lines like this
check just disastrous for white
of course you could take here covering
g3 but it all looks shaky pretty shaky
so g3 is a move
I don't think Yuma player would consider
um kramnik plays a human movie played
rook a3 which covers the third-ranked
especially the sensitive f3 square so on
an understandable decision Yunel played
rook a to c 8 yeah using the a8 rook and
opposing this look on c1 yeah white does
not really have anything better than
taking on c8 this rook is hanging and
moving it away does not lead to much he
changed and played the route back to a 1
so this wasn't the most successful
operation but it's a very difficult
position anyway to play and kramnik
really doesn't have didn't do anything
wrong here the position is still equal
but equal in a very young dynamic way
there's still lots of things going on
and if I remember correctly I don't have
information in my my notes iam about the
time spent but the Kramnik was down on
time this um happened frequently in the
match
Queen c5 activating the Queen and
intending to use it maybe only 5 we see
this see this later queen g4 played
attacking here and controlling g8 and
now Queen e5 like centralizes the Queen
and keeps it closer to the king so black
has a nicely centralized position all
pieces are active it's not easy to play
for white especially considering that
this night is a bit is a bit off site
this is also why played
three getting it back into the game and
Queen to f6 chronic not related rook e1
preventing 95 this was the possibility
for black so he prevents that and rook
c5 again introduces this idea yeah now
befall was played kicking a rock and
setting these pawns into motion and now
look c3 yeah now we get to them to the
critical point of this game kramnik here
being somewhat low on time played them
at first very nice looking with Knight
eggs deform I remember I watched this
life back then and resold a while I
thought wow it's Dwight wide winning now
played 1984 but in fact this contains
goddesses supports the pawn like has set
up a very nice trap him we see an why
this is not working what he should do
probably is to play a 92 getting away
this night from this possible capture
and this position is still super
difficult to to play black is still
nicely centralized active pieces but
these are also strong pawns and yeah
well you know this King can get in this
view I can can become a problem the
position is still completely unclear if
you give it to a modern day computer and
already five years ago this games played
it it's about it's about equal
the computer assessment but this is just
yeah this is just some numbers given by
machine human players with limited time
here we'll the put up we will do lead to
a very tough fight and you don't know
what is going to happen it's just a very
unclear position which is exactly what
Anand was looking for getting this kind
of complicated to knocking positions and
then and Cromley carolien have made this
mistake not xt for if you don't know the
game you can treat this as a puzzle if
you want and try to now calculate the
the coming line yeah keep silent for a
couple of seconds so you can pause the
video to try to calculate the coming
complications alright I continue now
it's of course not only the next move
which is probably have very clear black
captures but what is the the big problem
that kramnik overlooked here we see
what's coming rooty one attacking the
Queen and of course the ideas if the
Queen now moves then Luke takes the
seven judges twins for white but black
has of course the move Knight f6
attacking on g4 this is probably what
chronics I didn't overlook the move but
the real problem comes a couple of moves
later Luke takes d4 what else
94 and now Jack gets the bishop back if
you try to calculate I hope you got this
far and now what you need to do is you
need to see the next two moves and this
is also a motif to remember that
sometimes really occurs in games check
just like here rook c1 check bishop f1
and of course you note back rank issues
but how to exploit it black has a cute
way to to instantly win the game and of
course
place instantly 93 this is the decisive
move
it's very nice just attacking the the
bishop and white white needs to capture
everyone else and after the recapture
there's the threat eetu utilizing the
pin on the first rank and there's
absolutely no way to prevent it the only
way to do so slightly delay it to c7 but
black and just take and return next move
after a Jeep or move check this check
check leads to being a whole rook down
not even an exchange or something and
after F takes e3 Kramnik in fact
resigned the game and that likes to are
not having a two-point lead after after
five games after which it's a 12 game
match both 12 damaged the match was
basically almost over
you couldn't really think that that
chrony could come back from being two
games down after five games especially
losing two white games which is really
unheard of he basically never loses his
white and he lost two white games in
fact anand directly after Game five in
Game six one get another game so he led
by three points after six games and
therefore the match was was really
decided Kramnik actually managed to win
a game and not quite sure game 10 or
something around game 10 to to to to
come come closer like only being two
points down but still hunted with no
problems
managed to to win the match even won one
game earlier then then needed so
excellent performance in in bond 2008
his best performance yet and yeah let's
hope that he will be in good shape again
kaolin that we have a good competitive
match one thing is clear if it's not in
absolute best shape that could get it it
could become a disaster but on the other
hand other minute as I mentioned if you
would somehow manage to get close to
this form of 2008 it will be a very very
interesting and tough match to to watch
yeah thanks for watching this game I'll
be back tomorrow showing one of
thousands finest wins from his best
tournament to date and this will be the
2009 lunging tournament in China yeah
let's talk again tomorrow about the game
from that tournament bye